someone is lying about open AI either
Sam ultman the board of directors or
both it is November 22nd 2023 and you're
watching the code report welcome back to
the program let's first do a quick recap
on what's happened over the last few
days on Friday around 300 p.m. Sam Alman
joins a Google meet where he fired by
open ai's board of directors including
Chief scientist and co-founder Ilia
suver a few minutes later an open AI
statement goes public explaining how
Alman was fired for not being
consistently candid in his
Communications with the board which
implies some sort of Lying by omission
open AI president Greg Brockman was also
demoted to assistant to the CEO however
he promptly quit rather than be
disrespected like this in addition Sam
Alman sent this cryptic tweet saying I
love you all making it obvious that Ilia
had betrayed him giving us a narrative
that plays out almost exactly like
Shakespeare's Julius Caesar where the
dictator becomes too much of a dick and
then when he sees a good friend among
his assassins says you two Brutus by
Saturday there were all kinds of
theories floating around like open AI
had discovered artificial general
intelligence or some other highly
dangerous digital consciousness and it
was too dangerous to have ultman at the
helm or maybe ultman was getting too
friendly with the Saudis raising money
for his AI chip
side and another thing making Alman look
bad is this letter from former openai
employees that contains various
allegations of dishonesty that need to
be investigated further however an
internal memo leak saying that his
firing wasn't due to any malfeasant or
technological issues now by Sunday Alman
was already back in the building with a
guest badge negotiating his return to
open aai with Microsoft CEO Sadia
Nutella these talks ended in a stalemate
because Saia wanted to use Microsoft
teams but the open AI board refused to
compromise on Google meet so ultman and
Brockman formed a new AI research team
at Microsoft and will likely be taking
many open AI employees with them on
Twitter tons of people started repeating
this cult-like chant open AI is nothing
without its people and a little Pro tip
here if you haven't done so already I'd
recommend sending out this tweet
yourself because you'll instantly get
multiple DMS with job offers over 500
open AI employees have threatened a quit
who could easily be absorbed by
Microsoft to completely dominate the AI
space now in what seems to be an
incredible ibly weak move Ilia suit
skver tweeted that he regrets his
actions in participating with the board
to fire ultman many people have said
that he's the brain behind open Ai and
the single most important figure when it
comes to the technology itself and he
sent this ominous tweet a few weeks ago
that said if you value human
intelligence above all else you're going
to have a bad time and now fast forward
to Tuesday November 21st ultman
officially leaves Microsoft and goes
back to open AI as CEO as of right now
the situation is still volatile but it
looks like Microsoft is going to come
out the big winner ultman himself is
also a big winner who now looks like an
replaceable CEO with overwhelming
support from employees what's weird
though is someone has to be lying the
board of directors indicated that mman
was lying about something very serious
because there's no way you just fire
someone who's as smart effective gay and
well-connected as Sam mman especially
right before Hanukkah most likely it
would be some kind of major conflict of
interest like where he's using his
position to make Bank behind everyone's
backs by forming ship startups with the
Saudis but it seems like if there was a
really good reason for his firing
somebody would have leaked that
information out by now to have it all
make sense in the first place maybe the
board is lying in and they didn't really
have a good reason to fire Alman aside
from the fact that they thought he was
becoming too powerful and influential he
was pushing AI commercialization too far
which some people think is a very
dangerous thing for Humanity therefore
the board took action to save Humanity
by getting rid of ultman at the first
possible opportunity but this also
doesn't make a ton of sense because they
had to have known this backlash was
coming and Alman could just go start his
own AI thing at Microsoft without the
arbitrary moral limitations imposed by
the nonprofit open AI others have
speculated that board member Adam
D'Angelo was behind the firing because
he's the CE o of qua which is an
unusable knockoff of Yahoo answers that
recently released its own AI product
called po then on chat GPT Dev day a few
weeks ago it immediately became obsolete
the problem is that D'Angelo is
returning to the board along with Alman
as CEO which means he's probably not the
source of the drama although he did vote
to fire Alman the board members not
returning are the two women Tasha
mccauly and Helen toner a big win for
the patriarchy and apparently toner and
ultman weren't playing well together
recently to replace them we've got Brett
Taylor who is the former chairman of the
board at Twitter before Elon took over
and Larry Summers who is the former
Secretary of the Treasury appointed
shortly after Bill Clinton did not have
sexual relations with that woman the
only other possibility is that everybody
is lying ultman the board and Microsoft
are all working together on a giant
publicity stunt as part of a grand
strategy to consolidate power and
Achieve regulatory capture where the
techn Kings get to regulate themselves
to carry on the tradition of crony
capitalism here in America to ultimately
make it impossible for anyone to compete
with open AI in Microsoft this was all
planned out in May of 2023 at the
Bilderberg meeting which was attended by
people like ultman nadela and Elite
insiders like Henry Kissinger they
borrowed the story from Shakespeare's
Julia Caesar to keep us all entertained
and if you enjoyed it you're really
going to like the next ACT where Alman
brings us his final alternative to man
that brings us back into Perpetual
balance with nature just as the guide
stones required welcome back to the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one